because I think it's really a marvelous
thing that visualization thing you did
you don't do I read about this or hear
this that you used to go up on
Mulholland Drive and play every night
and visualize seeing yourself is yeah I
would visualize yeah broken polar right
having directors interested in me and
people that I respected saying you know
I like your work or whatever that is and
and I would visualize things coming to
me that I wanted or whatever this was in
like nineteen eighty seven eighty five
yeah and I had nothing at that time so
it was like but it just made me feel
better it made me at that time all it
really was for me was kind of making me
feel better I would drive home and think
well I do have these things and they're
out there I just don't have a hold of
them yet but they're out there so didn't
you write yourself a check I heard that
you did is that true wrote myself a
check for ten million dollars for acting
services rendered and I gave myself five
years there were three years maybe and
and I dated at Thanksgiving 1995 and I
put it in my wallet and I kept it there
and it deteriorated and deteriorated and
stuff and and but then just before
Thanksgiving 1995 I found out that I was
gonna make ten million dollars on thank
you food dumb and dumber
dumb and dumber yeah I read this book
because I was in disbelief as people
here's the strategy for success of the
secret right go into your house and do a
quiet room and you close the lights draw
the shades and sit on a couch and
visualize a big fat check twenty-five
G's thousand bucks us okay with your
name on it and I want you to imagine
that check and just make that check go
bigger in your mind and make it real
more real and just put it out into the
ether of the universe and the law of
attraction will take whole just think
about it oh right
hello if that's their strategy for
success the only thing we'll throw up in
your mailbox is not the cheque it's a
freaking eviction notice from your
landlord
they'll be towing away your car your
wife or your husband all for the
next-door neighbor and you'll be still
saying where's the check where's the jig
we're okay
the secret is a load of crap okay do I
believe in manifestation yeah damn
straight I do but you got to take action
I'm one of those unfortunate people I
tried it I really do I tried it but I
read the book so let me try you know so
I said I'm trying to pray for the check
never came but I went out and slow
taking action guess what the check came
with extra couple of zeros my intention
with this video was just read
understanding not fighting I want you to
see that it's not one point of view or
the other you can toll and learn from
both especially the one that you don't
immediately resonate with embrace the
genius of the ant